am anfang war das erklärt
pferde aus goldstaub oder ein elefant
der kunst stück gemacht
alles ohne den einsatz leben der tiere
das deutsche traditionsunternehmen
roncalli führt mit hologrammen den
zirkus in ein neues zeitalter für
direktor werner paul ist wandel ein teil
des geschäfts die die lebensumstände für
tiere haben sich geändert
deswegen muss man auch dem rechnung
tragen
man muss die welt beobachten und auch
die veränderungen und die
kurskorrekturen vollziehen immer wieder
zu beginn der show sind hologramme die
stars der manege
[Musik]
dann geht s real weiter in lübeck ist
der zirkus mit dem programm storyteller
gestern heute morgen zu gast
das konzept die romantische welt des
zirkus ins 21 jahrhundert zu
transportieren
für die zukunft steht neben den
hologrammen ein artist der mit einem
industrieroboter interagiert zirkus muss
überraschen
ich weiß genau was jetzt kommt das habe
ich noch nie gesehen haben verschiedene
outdoor elektrisches licht usw
das wurde im ziel gebracht als sensation
und wir bringen jetzt für holographie in
zirkus
markus strobel kontrolliert vor jeder
show die technik und die
projektionsfläche 11 computergesteuerte
laser beamer projiziert bilder auf ein
hauchdünnes metallisches netz die
investition in die zukunft ließ sich der
zirkus rund 500.000 euro kosten
ein schaden bereinigt und da haben wir
eine schneiderin und faden
aber das ist wirklich natürlich kinder
die sitzen in der ersten reihe und
denken sich wenn ich mal dahin fassen
eine auf extended reality also
erweiterte realität spezialisierte firma
im ruhrgebiet warte die umsetzung
verantwortlich
idee und konzept stammen von roncalli
zunächst wurden am computer 3d
animationen der figuren modelliert
auch das zirkuszelt hat das team um
bürger wunderlich virtuell nachgebaut
so konnte der blickwinkel der betrachter
zur projektionsfläche und den
animationen errechnet werden
tatsächlich ist so ein elefant von
oberflächenstruktur auch sehr aufwendig
das heißt natürlich haben wir elefanten
fotos die dort als textur drauf liegen
aber so ein elefant hat auch herrchen
das heißt wenn man nachher diesen
elefant maler manege sich anschaut der
hat über 40.000 herrchen das zu
modellieren oder beziehungsweise zu
rendern das macht das ganze schon
spannend im 300 quadratmeter großen
studio wurden die hologramme getestet
hier kann ein viertel ihrer
originalgröße abgerufen werden
nicht alle figuren zum teil der
aktuellen show
also interaktion macht das ganze
natürlich viel viel spannender in
zukunft dh die artisten können direkt
mit den holografischen elementen
interagieren sie können wir an künstler
mit den elementen neue arrangements
gestalten welten zusammenstellen und
sich dann durch diese welten bewegen
für die aktuelle tournee wurde
zirkusdirektor berner paul vor grünem
hintergrund gefilmt und dann in einen
virtuellen ballon animiert
doch hielt den zuschauern bei den
hologrammen nicht dass zirkus gefühl
bereits des spontanen oder ist hier frei
einfach zeitgemäß so atemberaubend dass
das auch so losging und als hat mir echt
gut gefallen das ganze habe ich noch nie
gefahr so gesehen nur für die
klassischen roncalli romantik wie sie
bisher erlebt habe und dort das
hologramm eben nicht bei der nächsten
tournee sollen die virtuelle und die
reale welt noch mehr miteinander
verschmelzen
eines steht fest der zirkus bleibt auch
in zukunft eine magische welt voller
überraschungen
[Applaus]
[Musik]